Lance Reddick might be gone, but the legendary
actor will never be forgotten. The cast of "John
Wick 4" took time during the premiere of the
film to pay tribute to their departed friend.
Lance Reddick, who played the Continental
Hotel's slick and savvy concierge Charon,
died on March 17 2023, aged 60. Reddick
appeared in all four "John Wick" films
and is slated to appear in the upcoming Ana
de Armas-led franchise spin-off "Ballerina."
Variety reports that attendees of the Los
Angeles premiere of "John Wick 4" were
asked to wear a blue ribbon pin upon entering
the TCL Chinese Theatre. Blue was Reddick's
favorite color. All of the event's attendees,
including lead star Keanu Reeves and director
Chad Stahelski had their snaps taken with the
simple but beautiful tribute. While speaking
with star Laurence Fishburne, Entertainment
Tonight noted that Reddick's character poster
was the first one to greet attendees at
the "Chapter 4" premiere. In general,
the atmosphere at the premiere was celebratory
but solemn. Fishburne told ET at the premiere,
"We lost our brother. We lost our brother."
Reeves also praised the late
actor during the red carpet,
describing Reddick as a "people person" and
"special artist" while speaking with Variety.
"It's just really something special,
every time he stepped on set,
to watch the passion he had for his
work. It's really easy to work with him."
As Reeves succinctly put it
while talking to Deadline,
"f–king sucks he's not here."
The love and respect for Reddick
and his "John Wick" character
continued inside the screening room as well.
"And as always, it's a
pleasure to have you with us again, Mr. Wick."
Before Keanu Reeves and director Chad Stahelski
took to the stage to introduce the film,
The Hollywood Reporter noted that
President of the Lionsgate Motion
Picture Group Joe Drake paid tribute to
Lance Reddick. Drake said to applause,
"It would be impossible to not acknowledge
how profoundly sad we are by
the loss of Lance Reddick."
The executive then acknowledged how impactful the
loss of Reddick was. In honor of the late actor,
Drake implored those in the auditorium
to celebrate the actor with applause.
"Tonight, what I would like to do,
however, is to ask you to make loud,
honoring, grateful applause for a man who
was an absolutely extraordinary human being,
extraordinary actor, and a
big part of this franchise."
Reddick received a standing ovation
from those in the cinema hall.
"John Wick: Chapter 4" screened after
an introduction by both Keanu Reeves
and Chad Stahelski. Variety,
in attendance at the premiere,
noted that Lance Reddick's first appearance
in the film received considerable applause
from viewers. Shortly after the film's
premiere, Deadline confirmed that "John Wick:
Chapter 4" was dedicated in Reddick's
memory. Stahelski told Variety,
"I just got to be happy and
be proud of the fact that I
got to spend so much time with
him. We're going to miss him."
While Reddick was widely celebrated
for his decade-long stint in John Wick,
the actor is also remembered for his starring
role in "The Wire." After his death was confirmed,
"The Wire" creator David Simon took to
social media to praise the actor, tweeting,
"Consummate professional, devoted collaborator,
lovely and gentle man, loyal friend."
In addition to his roles on
the big and small screen,
Reddick was an integral part of
Bungie's "Destiny" video game,
where he played Commander Zavala. The hours
following his passing, thousands of "Destiny"
players took to Zavala's in-game location to
pay tribute to the actor. The act of kindness
and support was later commended in an official
statement by Lance Reddick's wife, Stephanie.
The latest "John Wick" film is Reddick's
first posthumous role. The actor will next
be seen in Hulu's remake of "White Men
Can't Jump" and will headline Disney+'s
adaptation of "Percy Jackson
and the Olympians" as Zeus.